sequels to movies will always come with
its bumps in the road but for Jake Sully
he may have a bit of a boring confusing
story problem after 13 years Avatar the
way of water has brought viewers back to
Pandora and into the life of ex-marine
turned full-time bloopers and Jake Sully
reactions to Avatar 2 have been strong
and for good reason it's visually
stunning utterly immersive and far
better on the narrative front than its
predecessor in short it's everything a
sequel should be given how much Cutting
Edge technology James Cameron brought to
bear for the film it should be no
surprise that the way of water looks
stunning and unlike any other film ever
made before by leaping into the future
and giving Jake and natiri a whole
family to look out for Avatar 2 adds
several meaningful layers to the
narrative the result is a relatively
simple but emotionally affecting story
about Parenthood growing up and
protecting the things you love
unfortunately the way of water is still
built on the shaky Foundation that is
the original movie and I was hoping for
some sort of tactical plan that didn't
involve martyrdom this doesn't hurt the
film too badly when it's focused on new
characters or big cinematic set pieces
but it becomes glaringly obvious
whenever Jake is back in the spotlight
while the reformed Jarhead is markedly
better in the sequel he can't escape the
problems of his past despite its best
efforts Avatar the way of water can't
shake its predecessors Jake Sully
problem the sad fact is that Jake Sully
is a terrible protagonist and barely
half a character in the original Avatar
Sam Worthington does his best to bring
some life and charm to the ex-marine but
the material he's given to work with is
just pitiful for those who haven't seen
the movie since its original release in
2009 let's do a little recap of Jake's
character Arc paraplegic ex-marine Jake
Sully arrives on Pandora to take the
place of his scientist's twin brother
whose Avatar was fully completed before
his untimely death Jake is given the
opportunity to learn the ways of the
Navi but he's actually spying on them
for the resources development
Administration after spending three
months without once mentioning the
impending danger to their Land Jake is
cast out by naturi when the humans
bulldoze home tree he then tames a big
bird that only five Navi in history have
ever ridden immediately regains the full
Trust of the clan and leads them to
Victory as their new Chosen One aside
from being grossly white Savory and
pretty ableist Jake story just flat out
doesn't make sense the only reason he's
welcomed is a hero by the navi is that
he tames the toric but doing so is so
simple that it drains the act of any
weight we learn nothing about his past
besides his military service record and
were never given a real reason to root
for him we're told that Jake is the main
character but he doesn't earn the title
the good news is that Jake is way more
interesting in avatar The Way of water
the bad news is that the film can't
fully fix his problems from the first
film making Jake a protective father
who's scared for his kids is a great
move and it leads to a far more
compelling Arc than the one in the first
movie but James Cameron still wants us
to believe that Jake is the hero of
Heroes and it just doesn't work the
Sully's arrival on the reefs of metcaina
would have been a perfect opportunity to
unpack some things from the first film
Clan leaders roano and tonawari are
hesitant at first to let them stay
pointing out their mixed blood features
is a reason that they wouldn't fit in
however they stopped short of
questioning Jake's legitimacy as a navi
leader it would make sense for ronell to
ask some questions like why are so many
Navi following this guy didn't he just
lie to us for three months and then ride
a giant bird but posing those questions
would be putting all of Avatar Into
question which is something Cameron
clearly isn't willing to do granted it's
been nearly two decades of Jake proving
himself but tanawari would still be
right to remain suspicious of Jake's
Origins
yes Jake humbles himself a bit and
becomes more vulnerable in Avatar too
but it's not enough to redeem his
character he still refers to himself as
a dumb grunt so why is he received like
a legendary leader maybe Cameron just
can't let go of the heroic Space Marine
myth but given how outright evil the RDA
is that message is confused at best
[Music]